lowry tough smart guy
i love that lowry threw up his hand and
acknowledged the foul oh yeah
now he's definitely trying to bow right
there's no question there
stand up guided i'm not sure he's going
to
stay in the game
he took a bad ball he's still eyeballing
kyle lowry and has a few more words for
the veteran point guard
and uh and zach zarba with the whistle i
think that they're gonna
take a look at this oh yeah there's
intent there yeah there's definitely
intent and
this goes back to the bubble man yeah
you know the
you know uh gordon got hurt
he appeared to have blamed kyle for
getting hurt
and that was definitely a
pre-planned payback of some sort
i would agree with you on that i mean he
just waited for kyle to come down and
just step right into it the ruling on
the floor is an offensive fouling goal
in a significant time but there were a
lot of words
when gordon left the court uh that got
game between kyle and him and
again that was a definite hey i
remembered it and here you're gonna get
one now
gordon went back to the locker room